i have a reputation in the industry as a
very successful professional chartered
captain
and you'll find that i'm not an [ __ ]
unless you don't follow the rules
no drinking on charter that's just not
going to happen
i've had
meltdowns i've had fires
i've had pirates chase me any scenario
you can think of has happened in my 27
years in this industry i don't want to
hear on my last boat
leave it on your last boat no those are
sharks dolores you don't like showers oh
my god
son of a [ __ ]
captain lee
dolores jumping in the water is the
ultimate view to the captain she's drunk
it's dark i don't need somebody
jeopardizing their own life on my watch
that is not going to happen i heard
splash there went someone in the water
oh jesus christ
do i need to jump in yeah i think you
should jump in quickly take off this
i'll go get her if you want it's like
what the
she's like totally disrespecting captain
lee she's disrespecting me she's
disrespecting all of the crew it's about
safety this has like reached another
level it's just mental
where is she she's over there are you
okay if james jumps in he's got his um
okay i'm sorry she's a super good
swimmer do you want me to i don't care
if she's a good swimmer she's had a lot
of wine to drink she's drunk you're
right i don't need dead bodies here
you have some bacon you can't have
anything you need to get your goddamn
ass back to this boat now
this lady gives zero
literally
zero
please go around to the other side of
the boat because there's no way for you
to get up here
so please go around to the other side of
the boat
i am very pissed at you captain he's out
there he's probably pissed
oh jeez now he's not gonna like us
anymore
you stepped over the line
i'm not gonna tolerate this behavior
much longer
i don't give a sh what you paid please
don't ruin our time your charter just
ended
please now get out get out get a swim
platform out here or a ladder
we're headed back to the dock
[Music]
i'm done
get her ass out of the water ready for
us to get some uppercuts oh yeah we're
getting chewed oh oh god
take a seat let's sit down
so what do you think this meeting's for
yeah
we're going to cheer us out for
something am i
do you think everything's 100
no if we just cruise for an hour and a
half and no fenders are up no lines were
ready this morning and you come out here
and i'm floundering around waiting for
you guys i gave you plenty of warning
this morning there's a lot of standing
around and having a chat
and i find the jobs aren't done
come on you guys should know that we
have to think ahead with common sense
i'm not going to walk around and
be your father you've got to be mature
and grown up yourself we looked better
the other day when we didn't know what
the hell we were doing with this boat
and had no bow thruster and wins we came
in here on a glorious day first time we
haven't had wind and we look like
first timers
i'm not gonna chew you out in front of
the other crew because that's
disrespectful
you as a team
pick yourselves up
train more on the full deck get on top
be more forward thinking
jamie
run your team
adam doesn't eat duck
what the [ __ ] does she it just defrosted
that on the fly she ate shrimp i can
saute up some shrimp i have that no
problem
shrimp
you like shrimp right no she doesn't
chicken chicken wants chicken
no i don't like chicken what do you want
oh my god i don't i swear to god what do
you like you have to express just
yourself you're a powerful woman do you
want lobster there's more without the
crab stuffing she likes lobster but okay
i hate chicken why do they fill out
these [ __ ] things
lobster without the crab who told you
she didn't like seafood when we did the
lobster bisque i said to her is there a
reason you're not eating it and she said
i don't like seafood i don't like to
complain the fact that you're not seeing
anything is making it worse what is your
preference
because i'm gonna give it to her
yes high five it's like taking the dog
and shoving it in its own poop to
get him to stop [ __ ] in the house
dislikes i don't really like eggs it's a
little lobster
i never even said anything i never i
never so i have it
i see it with my own eyeballs these
guests are impossible so i'm going to
defend my crew you actually have
shellfish on here yeah i do like
shellfish oh
[ __ ] for real
apparently oh sorry you just said you
didn't eat seafood yeah i did i i never
said oh my god you did say that we don't
know what you like so stop talking about
my eating
my lobster is amazing and his plating is
beautiful i don't feel upset
what's happening
i know you tell me
well it's too quick at the end at the
end there that was way too quick though
communicating out of my hands
communicate so you just slow up and i
slide up it was just too quick
secondly we never put the boat on the on
the stern until the anchors up we always
do we don't let's try to do everything
safely that's all
mate i've landed helicopter pulled off
at the same time turned a drop down
could come back i'm doing everything
safely there's nothing wrong with
picking up an anchor in five knots and
actually saving yourself half an hour
there's nothing unsafe about that at all
i'm talking about you just saving some
time with your crew by pulling in
fenders putting whips that could be done
prior hook the tender up pick up the
anchor at the same time that is doable i
know what you're saying but i don't have
a team of people that are 100 confident
with everything either
right this is not the conversation
you need to have with me
you need to have this conversation your
crew go and have it with them i'm just
telling you things that should be done
to actually save a load of time
go and have it with them yeah
i wouldn't do anything unsafe because
i'm responsible for it he's just
protecting his crew however if he wants
to be a good leader he's got to explain
to him we are working in a safe
environment i spoke to the cappy i want
it done
so the last one we're going to talk to
on our incident reports is going to be
leon
it was never my plan to have a grease
fire yeah has she been nice to you
leon
we're just finishing up the incident
reports
oh well
every time you have an incident on board
a vote you kind of go through that yeah
the choosing people are in isn't it
really
what a great attitude we have protocol
to follow
i just wanted to get your take
if you had any conversations with
anybody or you're taking bobby's okay
put the popcorn in the microwave she
threw the pizza in the oven rocky said
that kate didn't pull any of the trays
out so she left obviously dry trays in
there dry clean pans don't start fires
just doesn't happen and
[Music]
no disrespect
she was drinking as well kid so
it's not the first time i've seen a
drink leon is trying really hard to
deflect the blame off himself
did you
see kate drink
not like not yesterday no i'm just
concerned with last night i'm not
concerned with anything that you didn't
personally witness i would expect the
chef to be very concerned about a fire
in his galley and he's more concerned
with bashing kate and about the
potential of sinking the boat because
his galley caught on fire kate's the
chiefs do and i asked you guys to work
it out like three charters ago
and
that hasn't happened he doesn't have to
like kate i don't care if he likes her
but he does have to work with her what's
the big deal
the less she talks to me
the bet like i said i talk to it maybe
10 minutes in a day no i can't that's it
i can't have it go on like it is i think
we need to work on our communication oh
okay look i'm listening to you but not
at the moment i'm a little bit busy okay
yeah if you speak about common courtesy
okay i don't i haven't got time to
listen to you kid i'm busy
great
but what you want to do about it what
would you like to do no you told me you
need to make that call
whatever you want to do i'll agree with
well i think we might need to agree that
this will be your last charter
and i would appreciate it if you knocked
these guys socks off this evening with
the last dinner you said you gotta find
me but i don't see the situation getting
any better
okay very good there um let's call it
there now there captain thank you
get rocky in the galley
i'm off
finish the dares off
ben i want that tow line on the tendon
here's the line on the tendon
captain captain i'm having trouble with
the toe line it's tangled it happens
every time any wasting time brother the
guests are here to enjoy their childhood
it's their time we need to be prepared
for them seriously i think you guys got
this i hope
i can help stupid things
cute little deck cans aren't they just
the hottest i'll go and see what they're
up to we're trying to get a whole day
charter it's like someone spent an hour
trying to tangle this that's got to be
done pre-charter delegate this is the
fourth charter jamie should know by now
put your crew in the locations prior be
prepared i'm going to drive the boat
he's got to drive the crew ready to go
this sorted hang on one sec are you
ready we're not jamie guess shouldn't be
waiting on us this should have been none
before the guest arrived did one of the
deck crew
like that get it ready please i'm here
i'm still doing it
okay leave it to you yeah
the captain's telling me to talk to my
team about this about that make sure
that doesn't happen again manage your
team i do all those things come on put
the life vest on the other person thread
it out yeah he comes and does it anyway
for me this needs to be better yeah i
know you're going to be the captain and
let me do my job yeah can i see you in
the bridge for a second
coming up now
if kelly doesn't start performing the
way i think he should i'll probably just
end up having to babysit him all the way
through the season
what's up cap you and i both look out
the same windows and we save the same
dirt
and i'm wondering how come nobody's
taken care of it lauren's been up since
6 30 and yet hasn't touched anything um
i want to show you this okay
that's all inside
okay that's that's it
but it's still there
we're not inside that's interior
well okay fine go downstairs and tell me
that salt is on the inside no that
that's that's right and it's been there
for two [ __ ] days
i feel like we get called out on a lot
of things and you don't always call kate
out on it you really want to go to war
on this
i don't i was just we can i got no
issues with it well i was just trying to
point out it seems like we're gonna
think there's a double standard you're
getting picked on come here let's go
look at it no i believe you can't okay
let's go in kelly's situation he's given
a second shot at redemption he should be
stepping forward front and center and
going
sorry about that cap i'll get on it it
won't happen again not just wallowing in
self-pity two days it's been like that
just to show you that it's not on the
inside okay are we clear yep we're clear
good i want it done roger that so what
is your person that's been up and doing
i'll deal with it
he won't pick on kate he won't mess with
the stews he's terrified of kate and it
makes my job more difficult because then
he just comes after me
mila please come up to the bridge
oh this is bad
captain hey
so um your attitude has been amazing you
have passion in the galley i can see it
of course you do
hearing from captain sandy that i have a
great personality is very pleasant i
really want to show you the third
charter that i can do it and i want to
not do any buffets even for lunch when
we played it wake up at like four or
five and show you i really want to prove
you
what do you think is gonna happen here
we've all worked really hard to
help her
so now there's no excuses you feel the
chef is a chef man it's that i have to
be good or gone just how it is
as a human being i have all the
compassion in the world but as a captain
i have to let you go
but i've worked on walls this size
people who have their own boats and
private planes were happy
i'm really sorry
okay
your decision is your decision and if
there is
no chance then thank you for your
support
of course i appreciate it
okay okay thank you thank you all right
of course it makes me feel awful
people like me who have big ego
sometimes
have to be put down to earth a little
bit but it makes me feel like i want to
work even harder
[Music]
[Music]
you